[Music]
welcome to Hannity we have a lot to
cover tonight coming up Senator Lindsey
Graham reacts to the Georgia grand jury
actually recommending that he be
indicted and later would RFK Jr run as a
third party candidate we will ask him he
is not happy with the Democratic party
and the process running for president
also Senator John Kennedy raising
eyebrows during a senate hearing today
when he read from lgbtq books featuring
explicit material by the way we'll show
a lot more later but as of now viewer
discretion is advised here's a preview
I put some lube on and got him on his
knees
and I began to slide into him from
behind
oh there's a lot more we'll have a lot
of that coming up but first tonight the
walls as we have been telling you are
closing in on President Joe Biden
earlier today the house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy officially now called for a
formal impeachment inquiry over the
president's role in his family's Shady
business dealings take a look
we know the bank records show that
nearly 20 million dollars in payments
were directed to the Biden family
members and Associates through various
Shale companies even a trusted FBI
informant
has alleged a bribe
to the Biden family
Biden used his official office to
coordinate with Hunter Biden's business
partners about hunter's role in barisma
the Ukrainian Energy company
despite these serious allegations it
appears that the president's family has
been offered special treatment
by Biden's own Administration
treatment that not otherwise would have
received if they were not related to the
president
these are allegations of abuse of power
obstruction and Corruption
and they weren't further investigation
by the House of Representatives
that's why today
I am directing our house committee to
open a formal impeachment inquiry into
President Joe Biden
the speaker then sent a letter to fellow
lawmakers after his remarks following up
on the announcement confirming that they
will have a conference meeting on
Thursday about this inquiry now
predictably the White House immediately
dismissed McCarthy's announcement with
spokesman Ian Sams from the White House
council's Office claiming Republicans
have found no evidence that Biden did
anything wrong before calling the
inquiry quote the extreme politics at
its finest really no evidence at all
whatsoever okay we'll get into that what
about the treasury departments nearly
150 suspicious activity reports or that
FBI's 1023 form that alleges by the way
from a credible FBI Source credible
defined by the FBI who previously had
paid this Source hundreds of thousands
of dollars alleging that Joe Biden took
official actions as vice president in
exchange for a lot of money to enrich
his entire family all all related to
corruption allegations from the bidens
related to barisma that is the Ukrainian
gas and oil giant what about the 5 000
emails that Joe wrote Under a pseudonym
while vice president including by the
way we found a new account auks
uncovered yesterday despite the endless
attempts by the Biden Administration to
block House Republicans they have
uncovered what is now amounting to a
trove of evidence now while they
publicly dismissed the inquiry into Joe
Biden now according to reports the White
House has been preparing for this moment
they knew it was coming reportedly
building out an entire war room inside
and outside of government inside a
government filled with spokespeople and
legal experts to counter the
investigations into both Hunter and Joe
Biden they have their work cut out for
them because evidence of Biden's
wrongdoing is now quite overwhelming and
questions around the family Shady
dealings well they need answers like how
did Hunter by Biden he was admitted to
be an addict at the time earned millions
of dollars from foreign businesses and
foreign countries with no relevant
experience in the country or in the
field of endeavor he's getting paid on
and according to the Johnson Grassley
report he received for example 3.5
million dollars from the former first
lady of Moscow and then later 120
million dollar investment in their real
estate fund uh they got the exact amount
of money from a Kazakhstan oligarch and
that money was spent instantaneously on
a brand new sports car by Hunter Biden a
hundred thousand dollars that
International shopping spree uh with an
Associate of a CCP backed Chinese energy
firm millions of dollars for his work on
the board of barisma he also demanded 10
million dollars uh remember I am sitting
next to my father from a Chinese
business associate at a CCP link firm to
quote further the interest of their
joint Venture now house oversight
committee chairman James Comer says the
Biden's overall have taken in tens of
millions of dollars from foreign
entities in Russia Ukraine China
Kazakhstan and Romania and many other
countries through these shell companies
allegedly used to conceal the source and
the funds and reduce suspicion over the
total amount so if it really is just
extreme politics at its worst as their
White House war room is now claiming
then explain what the bidens do did to
earn all of this money tens of millions
of dollars why was Hunter Biden paid
Millions by barisma and a you know CCP
linked energy firm cesp uh C uh in China
despite having no experience at all
whatsoever in energy Ukraine China no
experience how much money in total did
Hunter and his businesses do with China
with Russia you Crane in all of these
countries how much money did the Biden
family profit in all of this did they
pay taxes on all of this money did they
follow the federal laws you know the
ones they used against people like Paul
manafort uh what did the other family
members do to earn this money now
Congressman Comer is saying even
grandchildren got paid okay what did
they do to earn their money how much
were they paid did they pay taxes why
did they set up all these show
corporations why did Joe lie repeatedly
that he never spoke to his son his
brother or anybody for that matter about
these foreign business deals and we know
just the opposite is true we are now
looking at what is potentially the
biggest bribery and money laundering
scandal in the history of this country
what role did Joe Biden your president
play in all of this now thanks to the
laptop from hell that's Hunter Biden's
laptop and eyewitness testimony his
involvement is clear still he spent
years lying to you the American people
in case you've forgotten let's remind
you
Mr Vice President how many times have
you ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I've never
spoken to my son about his overseas I
have never discussed with my son or my
brother or anyone else anything having
to do with their businesses period And
what I will do is the same thing we did
in our Administration there will be an
absolute wall between personal and
private uh and and the government do you
stand by your statement that you did not
discuss any of your son's overseas
business yes I stand by that statement
all right those were all lies from
candidate Joe Biden President Joe Biden
and according to Congressional testimony
from Hunter Biden's former business
partner Devin Archer well Hunter
connected Joe with foreign Associates
more than 20 times to promote the Biden
family brand what's the brand it
certainly wasn't Hunter it was Joe and I
know to talk about the weather has one
Democrat suggested a little far-fetched
but it wasn't just over the phone
there's photographic evidence we also
know of Joe meeting with Hunter Biden's
uh foreign business associates in person
on numerous occasions and further
eyewitness testimony from Devin Archer
confirming he attended a lavish dinner
at the ever so prestigious Cafe Milano
in 2014 when he was still vice president
attended by the former first lady of
Moscow Elena batarina just days before
she wired well one of Hunter's shell
companies 3.5 million dollars and
according to message images from the
laptop from Hell Joe's involvement is
even deeper Hunter once complaining to
his own sister about giving half his
salary to Pops and paying his bills and
requesting advice from Rosemont seneca's
money guy by the name Eric Sherwin which
account should we use for this various
home repair of pops and that various
home repair of Pops looks like pops
might have benefited from all this while
another message reveals Hunter and his
business partners set aside 10 percent
of their earnings for quote the big guy
later identified as Joe according to
multiple sources including Tony
bobolinski Hunter even reference sitting
next to Joe while demanding payment from
his Chinese business partners I'm
sitting next to my father remember that
one uh well within a week there was all
the money right in their account was it
five ten million dollars but perhaps the
biggest slam dunk case against the
bidens involves barisma in large part
because Joe himself bragged about his
role in this case in 2015 Joe was
leading up the Obama administration's
Ukraine policy he leveraged one billion
U.S tax dollars to have the prosecutor
investigating Barista fired while Hunter
sat on the board making millions later
bragging about it as a result of the
firing son of a bee hunter continued to
get paid the family continue to get
enriched as a result of this brag by Joe
Biden
I had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko and from uh yats and yuk that
they would take action against the state
prosecutor and they didn't so they said
they had they're walking out to Prescott
said no I said I'm not going to or we're
not going to give you the billion
dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting the billion dollars I said
you're not getting a billion I'm going
to be leaving here and I think it was
what six hours I looked I said I'm
leaving in six hours if the prosecutor
is not fired you're not getting the
money oh son of a
you got fired and they put in place
someone who was solid
he got fired Hunter continued to get
paid James Comer is now demanding the
state department explain the sudden
decisions leading to the firing of the
prosecutor which begs another question
why did Joe lie about his involvement in
Hunters business dealings is he trying
to hide something and new today House
Republicans they're coming forward to
accuse Hunter's attorneys of
intimidating IRS whistleblowers who did
come forward with allegations of
misconduct and special treatment for the
Biden family hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else